if you're going to actually place a bet
on a non-sovereign store of value
the dollar is not it the euro is not it
bitcoin is the first thing if we just
look at
distribution price is simply what two
people decide to exchange a small amount
of any asset for it has nothing to do
with the value wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you do you have
michael jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn what successful people
think about
bitcoin enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one invest in dominant assets with
michael saylor if you pull in your time
frame to less than a year less than 12
months and you and you consider you know
regulatory uncertainty and market
liquidity crisis like just about
anything can happen
and we just saw an example with the
china exodus with a major shock
which drived a lot of a lot of people
had to forcibly liquidate their holdings
in china if you look at it was a
crackdown not just on bitcoin mining
it's a crackdown on bitcoin holding
and the ownership of it
so you can see things like that and you
can see that
ripple through all the leverage in the
crypto markets that's why i think
trading it and uh speculating it are
really difficult what's the most popular
monetary asset in the world the dollar
what's the second the euro what's the
third the third is bitcoin so
so of the top three the only one that's
going to go up in value as we print more
money is bitcoin and and then if i want
to go find another scarce asset
everything else apple stock google stock
every other crypto
is less popular so i'm looking at
bitcoin as uh the most distributed
strongest brand
of a monetary asset in the world so if
you're going to actually place a bet on
a non-sovereign store of value
the dollar's not it the euro is not it
bitcoin is the first thing if we just
look at
distribution so in that case you just
take a 10-year time horizon and say okay
well bitcoin is a
is a digital property i'll wait 10 years
and if there was one that was more
successful like how did i choose
facebook because facebook was the
dominant social network how did i choose
apple because they had the best most
dominant iphone how did i choose google
pretty obvious right i didn't choose
them
when they were five percent of the
market i chose them when they were 40 50
60 on the market but they'd only
penetrated two three percent of where
they're going to be
i think in terms of you know addressing
the issue is bitcoin a monetary or an
inflation hedge
head on well i mean i when i'm looking
at numbers
you take the 10-year view you know and
the 10-year average you know growth rate
of bitcoin is 116 and gold is 1.6
so it's pretty clear that gold is not
serving as an inflation hedge in the
past decade compared to bitcoin
if i take the 10-year uh 10-year numbers
for the s p it's 12.34 right now
if i take nasdaq it's 7 it's 18
obviously big tech is doing better than
s p s p is doing better than gold
bitcoin is doing better than them all
if i look at the last 12 months
we dumped a lot of liquidity in the
market so what happens well you know
gold is down one percent
the money passed gold s p is up 39
percent
uh people piled into the s p index as a
store of value
nasdaq is up 44
the long bonds are down 11 bitcoins up
277 percent
if i'm looking at those numbers the
story it's telling me is that in an
environment where you're printing a lot
of liquidity
either over the near term of the long
term
people are choosing big tech
then they're choosing equity and they're
they're choosing crypto overall
now i focus on bitcoin because i see
bitcoin as the risk off crypto asset
right it's like the sovereign if you're
looking for the long bond or the
sovereign debt of crypto i mean it is
the most uh risk off asset ethereum and
the other some of the other ones they
can show higher you know higher gains
from period of period but there there's
more risk in them
you know it's like not hating on them
it's just risk on risk off rule number
two understand money with raul paul what
gets worse about this is this affliction
this crypto affliction we all get right
the rabbit hole as it's known you start
with understanding money which most of
us don't think about then you kind of
understand how we're getting screwed by
central bank printing
and that the debt-laden economy and what
it means
and then you start saying okay but
that's bitcoin and then what's this
ethereum business
and then you start realizing
decentralized finance you're like it's
kind of a finance thing but that's kind
of cool because i can get yields now you
know i can get instead of getting zero
on my bank account for my hard savings i
can now get six percent a year wow
that's a difference it's like going back
25 years in time
and then suddenly nfts come
and community tokens
and suddenly your mind is completely
blown that this is not just money it's
the entire exchange
transfer and storage of value
for the internet
whole business models are about to
change
massively because of what this
technology
unlocks and then once you get your head
around that you're like oh god i can't
even hold this in my mind any longer
it's so big
um and that it's not just buy some
bitcoin i'm going to make some money
over time
you know it's actually an entirely
parallel financial system
and business structure
for the world and it's being adopted
faster than anything we can ever imagine
rule number three be smart with robert
kiyosaki bitcoin is important it's going
to crash
i think if it goes to 27 000 a coin i'm
going to back up the truck i'm going to
buy more
because i'm very optimistic about
bitcoin and let me explain why but also
why the risk is here
this is macro financial education
because in 1960 and 1980 my generation
the boomers didn't like stocks because
everybody
at my time of when i was a kid everybody
said anybody invest in the stock market
as a gambler
now everybody's in the stock market so
how did that happen
well in 1974 they brought this thing
called a 401k out i won't touch that
thing i would not touch a 401k or an ira
why because i don't have to
you know they tell you
exactly to tell you when to wear the
mask and when to get a vaccine they tell
you what you can invest in in a 401k in
an ira
i refuse to do that
i refuse to do that but i don't have to
do that
because as an entrepreneur i create my
own assets
i don't need the stock market you do i'm
not saying don't invest in i'm not
saying don't have a 401k don't have an
ira gold will not crash
but crypto could
you know why because the fed doesn't
want it
because the reason i like crypto the
reason i buy bitcoin and ethereum and
all that stuff is i don't like the fed
when i talk to most of the young guys
they don't like the fed either
but the problem is and this is why
you've got to be smarter
is that the fed wants to take this out
the european central bank these ecb
wants to take it out the bank of japan
wants to take it out the bank of china
wants to take it out
so that's why you crypto guys you've got
to be smarter today you don't just sit
there and go
so your crypto guys you got to be
smarter because what
possibly it hasn't happened yet is a fed
coin or a yuan coin a chinese coin china
channel probably have it before the us
and they will be a european coin
and that'll destroy the they'll destroy
they want to destroy bitcoin
so you guys in bitcoin you've got to be
smarter
so as it's coming down like i said i'm
still going to buy more
but when it passes 27 000 i'm going to
back up the truck just like i did when
it passed
9 000
because that's
that's what uh
traders do
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four know when to buy
with kathy wood i think we're in a
risk-off period and uh for for all
assets if you if you look at the the
stock market the the more risky or
volatile parts of the market have come
in dramatically since mid february and i
think a lot of the concerns have been
around inflation initially that was
helping bitcoin uh because obviously
bitcoin is a very important inflation
hedge you know it's a it's a rules-based
monetary policy the first global
rules-based monetary policy we have ever
had hugely important reserve currency of
the crypto asset ecosystem uh but i
think uh what's happening right now is
because the stock market the highly
volatile part of the stock market the
innovation
oriented part of the stock market has
gone through such a correction which has
been flamed by inflation fears uh i
think i think the correlations uh among
volatile assets are going to one right
now and that's including bitcoin do you
think we go much lower from here
uh you never know how low is low when a
market gets very emotional
uh a lot of traders see bitcoin uh
dropping below the 200-day moving
average uh which is which was at 40 000.
uh so traders once that happened they
just dumped some just uh dump and run
i think we're in a capitulation phase uh
yasin has
a dashboard we were looking at all the
indicators this morning they are all
suggesting that we are in the
capitulation phase which is a really
great time
to buy
no matter what the asset is a
capitulation phase is
buy it's on sale now
am i saying 35 000 is the low you know
if traders uh and there are a lot of
speculators in in bitcoin if they are
uh running for the hills just because uh
bitcoin has broken through a moving
average that is important to them it
could continue but uh all of our
indicators are saying this is
capitulation right now rule number five
understand the market with mark usco
their latest 250 000 for bitcoin but
within a five-year window which i have
to say uh is not as bullish as other
guests who have i've had on calling for
that target this year alone
yeah look you know what's interesting is
i i say that
the idea that that any of us
know what the price of of any asset is
going to be in the very short term
is really
kind of crazy in the sense that
one of the challenges we have for all
assets is is the value of something
is relatively easy to determine there
are cash flow models for stocks and
bonds and and there are
dividend discount models and there are
you know other models for networks and
there's metcast law and all the things
that people have applied uh to come up
with what the value
of the asset or the value of a network
will be the hard part is the price
because the price as i stole a line from
john burbank the famous hedge fund
manager price is a liar
and price is simply what two people
decide to exchange a small amount of any
asset for it has nothing to do with the
value people exchange at low prices when
it's below the fair value people
exchange at high prices
well above fair value and it's like a
pendulum right it spends very little
time in dead center it's usually too far
to the left or too far to the right
same thing true with bitcoin's price
it's rarely on the value and so my
forecast is really about the value
of the network and the value of the
network comes from the users from the
transactions from the blocks and all the
things that we can put into a model that
say the value of the network
right you know should be according to
this then this is a model that that i
borrowed which means stole because
picasso said good artists borrow great
artists steel
that i i stole from somebody back in
2014
and uh it basically uses metcalf's law
to draw parabola and it's a you know
non-linear logarithmic regression which
most of us are really bad at uh math is
hard and
long story short it said it'd be ten
thousand dollars in value in november of
2017.
pretty good call we hit it almost six
days to the to the day
but then the price went all the way to
20 000 and then crashed all the way to 3
000. so the price was very different
than the value this same model says the
value by july of this year will be
around a hundred thousand dollars
and so
and now five years from now to be 250
000
now what is possible i won't say likely
but it's certainly possible that like in
2017 and like in 2013 the price goes
much above
value
in the fall of this year because
individuals come in and what happens is
all markets migrate
ownership the original owners of any
asset are investors right they buy it
because it's below its fair value and
they want to hold it for the long term
and then as things start to move the
traders come in and the traders are
looking for things that are moving in
one direction or another and have a
shorter duration of hold
the problem is when the speculators come
in when the speculators come in they
only buy what's moving and they really
only buy what's moving up
and they use leverage and so what
happens is they push the price way above
fair value
and in this latest cycle in december in
january
we had some gamblers show up and
gamblers usually don't play
in financial markets right they usually
go to vegas or gamble online
but because the lockdowns with kovid
they didn't
have any place else to go so they
gambled in the stock market like
gamestop and amc and they gambled in
crypto and that's why i think we got a
little further away from fair value in
uh the last couple months that we should
have and that's why we've had this kind
of vicious correction here recently and
a speculator actually plays in markets
where the expected outcome
is not negative
right gambling
is a negative net present value activity
if you go to las vegas
and you gamble a lot
you will lose money because the house
wins the odds are tilted in the house's
favor and the only way you win in
gambling is if you win early you get
lucky and you stop
that's how you win and so the same
thing's true here is if if you got a
stimulus check from the government and
you had no knowledge of cryptocurrencies
other than hey that price is going up
that's a gamble that you can buy it and
then sell it at a higher price to some
greater fool
and get your money back
however
if you're foreign to that market which i
love your word use of the word foreign
because that's what it is if you're
foreign to that market you might not
know what the triggers are or what
happens when a bunch of highly levered
speculators right again who do this for
a living start to get liquidated
in china and we see prices fall you know
thousand point candles or you know three
thousand point candles
that is a very different environment and
the average i tweeted about this a while
ago look if you bought something
because the price was moving up and the
price starts going down you will sell it
right because you have no conviction you
have no courage you did no work
it doesn't make you a bad person it just
acknowledge it for what it is it's
speculation or gambling if you're an
investor and the price of an asset falls
to a level that you believe is below the
fair value not only will you not sell
you'll buy more rule number six go safer
with alex machinski you have to
understand that let's say tomorrow
morning somebody hacks bitcoin or
ethereum because they have the world's
uh strongest computer
and nothing happens to the history of
blockchain it's just that going forward
we have to fork the chain and make it
quantum resistant
and uh today the most sophisticated
computers uh running
uh probably 400 cubits that's like the
latest and greatest stuff that's uh
still in testing in labs
and you need thousands of these qubits
to be able to
uh even
try to attempt to
uh break the hash 256
encryption
um
i think that uh
you know we are years away from that
happening and uh
almost every chain has the
time to effectively become quantum
resistant
also
these chains are are the young chains
have a much higher
um uh risk of being hacked because
they're not as resistant right because
on bitcoin you have to hack or you have
to break
12 years worth of blocks right the where
on the new chain you might have to break
only one year worth of blocks so the
bitcoin is definitely a thousand times
more secure and more safe than anything
that comes after it and maybe the second
safest network would be ethereum but
bitcoin is a thousand times more safe
because it's a logarithmic scale it's
not a linear scale
with the need how much computation you
need to break the chain so i don't see
any of that happening in the next five
to ten years and rule number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is target millions with robert
breedlove bitcoin itself
is not a network that is going to
conform to any jurisdictional law
whatsoever and that's what makes it so
important frankly
that it's the one monetary network we've
ever had in history that does not
respond to coercion or force
so
try as they might
i'm sure you know the us government
in all its wisdom will gradually adapt
to the bitcoin network
find a way to
monitor and tax the transactions as best
that they can
but in the long run
as we can get more deeply into i see
bitcoin as fundamentally disruptive to
gold
uh and government and central banking
itself is an apparatus built on top of
gold
so i do think that this this wave of
innovation is
massive and it's something that
it's very difficult for us to even
comprehend in our world views it's
long-term repercussions because you told
robert kiyosaki about a month ago that
in 10 years time in 2031
you see bitcoin at 12 and a half million
dollars but with an inflation-adjusted
value of around 1 million dollars
meaning the current purchasing power of
1 million
per bitcoin do you maintain that outlook
i do maintain that outlook um and this
is based on
percentage expansion rates of money
supplies historically so the united
states expanded him to over 30 percent
last year
and it's easy to forget and mankind has
forgotten this repeatedly throughout
history and usually takes a few
generations each time
that the expansion of the money supply
is governed by a law
it's called the law of accelerating
issuance and depreciation
so the more money you print
the more money you ultimately later have
to print just to keep the system
uh going
so i do expect the expansion of usm2 to
double again probably in the next four
years
and then i expect it to double again
from there so we'll be north of 100 usm2
expansion annually by the end of the
decade
um at the same time because money has
this
century uh
centripetal network effect we tend
towards one that's what gold was that's
what the us dollar is
i do expect a lot of the weaker
international currencies to collapse
into the dollar during this transition
so i would say that um
global
uh m2 today is about 100 trillion
dollars usm2 is about 20 trillion so
it's roughly 20 of that i would expect
usm2 to expand to be about 40 of global
m2 by the end of the decade
but global m2 itself will have expanded
from 100 trillion due to this law of
accelerating uh issuance and
depreciation to about 1.25
quadrillion which is 250 trillion
dollars
and in that time as well i expect
bitcoin
as
essentially the ultimate
irrepressible non-counterparty insurance
policy against central banks to
appreciate in tandem
so i think its purchasing power will
increase to a hot to a million dollars
in 2021 purchasing power but by that
time due to the expansion in the money
supply from 100 trillion usm 2 to 1250
trillion m2 bitcoin will actually be
nominally valued at 12.5 million dollars
u.s by the end of the decade
further at that point
uh currencies tend to start
hyperinflating so i actually think fiat
currency globally will be collapsed by
the mid-2030s but what makes you so
confident still that bitcoin is going to
be the solution here
bitcoin has introduced
properties of money that are as close to
perfect as the world has ever had
and so what i really challenge people
that are skeptical of bitcoin to do is
to ask themselves
first of all the question what is money
and then secondly
why was gold selected by the free market
as money why has gold stood the test of
time for over 5 000 years
what are the properties of gold that
caused it to be selected
and if you do that digging you do that
homework you're going to end up very
deep into austrian economics at some
point which is
the cumulative wisdom of humanity on
economics
and it stands in counter distinction to
keynesian economics which i would
classify more as central bank propaganda
and gold and money in general is
essentially selected based on five
properties
i've covered this a lot in my work
they are divisibility durability
recognizability portability scarcity i
won't expand upon them here but you know
feel free to
dig some into austrian economics or
check out my work to see why
and essentially across those five
properties of money bitcoin has
perfected them in a way that the world's
never seen before
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the good deed of the
day this is something new i believe that
you're able to serve and it feels so
good to do something nice for somebody
else so good deed of the day put down in
the comments one thing that you need
help with that you're working on you'd
love some support or guidance on and
then two go
comment on somebody else's comment and
give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well the way you have to think about
this there's a lot of excitement within
the crypto community particularly around
bitcoin that it's to the moon you've
heard that expression many times and
that it won't be long before it's a
hundred thousand dollars a coin
none of that's going to happen unless
the institutional market starts to
buy this as an asset class and for all
the hype and excitement and all the you
know discussions that have been going on
online and on social media the truth is
institutions haven't touched this yet
not the real institutions not the
sovereign funds not the pension plans
very very few are involved in it and one
of the major reasons if not the reason
is that they all now have to be
compliant to sustainability and ethics
committees and the way you have to look
at that is
you know you've got let's say you're
managing
50 billion dollars you're you're a
sovereign fund
and you are concerned about the
long-term investment that's the nature
of what they do
and so you concern yourselves about the
issues that that the people you're
serving care about and one of those that
has been coming and moving right up the
hip parade is sustainability esg
you've seen it happen at the corporate
level there's a very famous letter that
came out of larry think of blackrock
just six months ago that really defined
what it meant
to be sustainable and climate change and
all of these things that people kind of
ignored for a long time but now at the
institutional level if you're sitting
with a sustainability committee on top
of the investment committee you have to
go through their filter first and their
filter has been very clouded by this
debate around sustainability and coin
mining you know there's many miners
particularly in asia and other foreign
countries that actually burn coal
to make bitcoin well that's not okay
anymore and that's why this debate has
come to the fore but but i say it's
important and it's a good thing because
if we can resolve this we can open up
the floodgate the log jam if you would
of institutional money that wants to
allocate to bitcoin so i as a bitcoin
owner want the institutional buyer to be
my incremental buyer that way i can see
price appreciation we're going to be
stuck in a rut here until we resolve
this issue and i think it's very
important to have an open forum about it
and have a dialogue i took a lot of
criticism when i raised this just a
couple of months ago now it's at the
four of everybody's discussions because
the industry has no voice it has no
lobby it has no way to fight back when a
single regulator a single state or a
municipality basically bans bitcoin or
tries to keep capital away by
threatening something like this there's
nowhere to go all you have is a
harassment of social media occurring but
no centralized voice or committee so i
applaud anything that tries to aggregate
the thought process and this there's
many different forms being proposed and
in fact there's a really big bit really
big bitcoin conference here in miami on
june 4th and 5th and this will be one of
the topics that's discussed because the
world is gathering here in miami and we
didn't know what the core issue would be
but certainly this is going to be one of
the big ones sustainability esg
institutional buying is all part of it
and i think the pressure that elon must
have felt when he announced that he
would take payment in bitcoin well a lot
of institutions that are his
shareholders in tesla that have provided
him billions of dollars of market
capitalization immediately jumped on him
and said i'm speculating when i say this
but i'm sure it happened wait a second
where did that coin come from how was it
mine how do you know it wasn't mind you
know in an in in sustainable manner or
one that wasn't sustainable at all and i
think that's the pressure that he felt
to come out and say wait a second i have
to rethink this and i want to talk to
miners remember there's only two and a
half million coins left to be mined
that's it and so it depends on what
happens to the next two and a half
million versus all the coins that are
out there already and that's the
dialogue the industry is having right
now but this issue is not going away it
is not going away and if we want to see
price appreciation whether it be on a
green coin or a sustainable coin or the
aggregate of already mined coins we're
going to need to solve for this because
the incremental buyer the institution is
where the next trillion dollars worth of
interest is going to come from
[Music]
if you want to know what warren buffett
elon musk mark cuban and others think of
bitcoin check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you're a true adventurer and
you really want to throw the hail mary
you might take 10 and put it in bitcoin
or ethereum but if you do that you've
got to pretend you've already lost your
money